bonjour vous regardez un court métrage
au format vertical qui se regarde sur un
smartphone si vous avez lancé cette
vidéo sur votre ordinateur votre télé
vous pouvez basculer c'est votre
téléphone et mettre la vidéo en plein
écran avec le petit bouton en bas à
droite est ce que c'est bon je suis en
plein écran alors bon visionnage
oui
oh
[Musique]
ah voilà
tout bon anniversaire
non c'est papa merci maman alors
j'imagine que tu as déjà plein de
copains qui t'ont souhaitait ton
anniversaire eh bien non non parce qu il
est 7h du mat ou êtes les premiers à a
alors c'est la grosse fête ce soir pas
vraiment puisque je suis né en plein
milieu doute et tous mes potes sont en
vacances mais j'ai l'habitude vous
inquiétez pas battu fait pas quand même
une petite fête 30 ans ça se fête oui
mais non je vais le faire chez moi sur
les flics ce sera très bien vous
inquiétez pas tout seul oh mais enfin
laisse me faire comme niveau
mais c'est quoi ce truc et je sais pas
si toi tu as dû encore touché un autre
humanité gonflé c'est toi qui t
intéresse c'est un filtre ne vous
inquiétez pas ça marche pas ce truc je
sais pas ce qui se passe à l' écoute
bonne journée
merci papa merci maman
oh
[Musique]
miroir
merci beaucoup pour ce cadeau au début
j'ai cru que ça allait être une baisse 5
mai à temps mais ton quand un stade
c'est carrément mieux ses mots
ban
[Musique]
oui
ouais cgt
le colisée c'est vrai c'est jusque ce
soir en fait je fais c'est pas que je
veux pas de voir enfin stiller
j'aimerais bien te voir mais d'ailleurs
y avait pas d'eau mais il ya ces jusque
carrément tu peux passer bien sûr il ya
une teuf avec mes potes afin que
quelques potes c'est un vrai plaisir de
te revoir voilà à ce soir
juste pour savoir comme ça les gars qui
est sur paris ce soir tout hasard c
happy birthday guigui from new york
appelée boulot
salue vous êtes bien sur répondeur de
polo vous pouvez laisser un message
juste après louis paul allard et bâtons
paulo ouais ben rappelle moi dès que
possible je j'espère que tu es sur paris
voilà
[Musique]
eh ben ce soit alors il viendrait avec
un truc pour annoncer les soualais tu
vas pas me faut que je le retrouve dans
mon bordel à ce soir bisous
envoyé un message à paulo que souhaitez
vous dire rappelle moi s'il te plaît
d'accord c'est envoyé
et
vers saint guillaume merci gentil 30 ans
et ça braie comptant sa fille dans les
années
10 mois tu
ce soir toi tu taintrux kodjo tu es mon
train pour la rochelle taton frappé
l'engin droite le boulot quand on en
vacances ouais t'as raison des vacances
ouais paulo ouais merci de me rappeler
un très bon anniversaire à quand un gars
assez peu d'imagés de ce soir toi tu je
retape rien au regard du thème ma
cousine et ce mari ne connais pas mais
bon anniversaire
on a terminé au il fait une chaleur mon
pote
tu voulais bien non non j'ai juste merci
c'est gentil
du boulot en fait je te laisse quoi
faire la fête salut à tous
et c'est une excellente nouvelle je les
retrouvais c'est tellement le bordel
dans mes tiroirs bref à tout à l'heure
wassigny fla fla
[Musique]
omer new york
ouais j'ai fait des petites provisions
pour ce soir donc faut que tu me donnes
ton adresse avant tu sens un agent
secret que ce soit totalement
confidentielles j'attends à tout
[Musique]
joyeux anniversaire
joyeux
anniversaire joyeux annie
c'est tout seul
[Musique]
joyeux anniversaire
tout seul
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
je pose dans des teintes à faire quoi
non vous vous êtes peut vous êtes ici
tout était à la mer tenir train de
mourir non non non pas du tout
[Applaudissements]
oh vous êtes vraiment des bad
quand est
ce qu'ils vont tout faire pour te faire
comme on l'a dit
salut mouillart
ouais bon anniversaire à 30 ans on garde
ça c'est
rien c'est ma cousine ex-mari
[Musique]
aucune idée et 20 mariages en bas de
chez moi donc j'ai pris une veste je
vais demander souhaiter un joyeux
anniversaire et cetto
[Musique]
s'est pas trop cramé ces genres macaca
ça ne soit pas n'est pas les petits
marron étonnant et alentours mais dans
le 15e on est bien à paris comme il faut
[Musique]
ok je sais pas
j'ai prévenu comme en bas c'est paulo
qui m'a jetée sur un stade aouita filet
l'adresse ok d'accord
[Musique]
chaque
hiver
les années
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où